gritos contra el racismo en Los Ángeles
es el último escándalo político en
Estados Unidos y va dirigido contra dos
miembros demócratas del concejo
municipal que participaron en una
llamada en la que hacían comentarios
racistas
estamos aquí para decir que Kevin de
León y Gil de Cedillo deben renunciar
ahora
[Aplausos]
no tenemos lugar para racistas
flagrantes contra los negros en el
concejo municipal de Los Ángeles se
tienen que ir se tienen que ir
los manifestantes quieren que se cierre
el consejo hasta que renuncien pero al
mismo tiempo se celebró un consejo
municipal todavía virtual por el covid19
este consejo no puede avanzar hasta que
tengamos esa renuncias y necesitamos que
todos los miembros del Consejo abandonen
esta reunión rompan el quórum la reunión
se celebró Y tomó posesión el nuevo
presidente Paul grecoriano quien se sumó
a las críticas contra el racismo
Los Ángeles ha visto un rechazo
abrumador a las declaraciones que
hicieron nuestros compañeros
la que sí dimitió la semana pasada es la
expresidenta demócrata del Consejo nury
Martínez fue por la filtración de una
llamada de octubre de 2021 llamó pequeño
mono al hijo de un colega y menospreció
a los mexicanos de Oaxaca la filtración
se produce a semanas de las claves
legislativas de medio término y en un
ambiente político donde las protestas de
las vidas negras importan de 2020
Todavía siguen muy presentes
[Música]